so i'm actually what i'm going to talk
about is a little something different
i'm going to talk about how
these forces that shaped human genetic
diversity and
relatedness between individuals actually
affect
our ability to identify which variants
are
involved in traits so the standard
approach
that people use to try to find variances
associated with traits is the standard
association
study and in this case you take a bunch
of individuals here this is a toy
example
each row is an individual a few of the
positions
uh differ in each in this toy example
there's two positions
and what you do is you correlate the
genetic variation with the trait to try
to identify
locations that are correlated because
those might be
variants that are involved in the trait
so in this example it's pretty obvious
which one of these two variants is
correlated with
blood pressure the the way i like to
think about
um how this kind of association test is
done is just
kind of visualize it just as a kind of a
standard regression here you have
uh the two alleles each individual is a
phenotype
each individual's phenotype is a dot on
the plot and
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to see which model fits better
either this
kind of linear model um with with uh
this
with no slope which is this kind of null
hypothesis and of no association
or a model that allows you to have a uh
you know a difference in the
in the means of the two uh of the
phenotype of the two alleles
and essentially you know there's the
details of how to do kind of this
regression
is you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of details but essentially it's
try to figure out which model which of
these two models fits better
um okay so if uh um so this is
again with the standard you know all of
the geos results that have been
found essentially use basically this
standard
linear model to do the association they
just look at
you know and if we represent our
individuals
in terms of matrices which will be
useful
y is basically a column vector of size
n we have individuals x is the snip that
we're going to test also column
matrix mu is the population mean
beta is basically the effect size of the
snip so the individual
if we can think of the snips as either
being 0 or 1 if you have it or not
or 0 1 or 2 how many allele copies you
have and
the beta basically means how much of the
phenotypic
what's the difference of phenotypic mean
for uh each of those
differs in each of those cases and then
um
e is basically the residual so it's kind
of the what we think of the contribution
for the environment
and in this case we just think of them
having some kind of
being drawn with with mean zero and some
some variance maybe sigma squared e and
in this case since
our in our data is actually a column
vector of individuals
our our residual is actually going to be
essentially a multivariate normal where
the covariance matrix is just going to
be
an identity matrix scaled by this
variance
okay so if this is how we assume this is
how we're doing the test
but of course this is not a realistic
way to think about
what's going on for how the how this is
actually realistic model for the the
trait so kind of a more a slightly more
realistic model
um which we can think of this kind of as
a hypothetical true genetic model if we
of course we don't know uh what the
effect is of each
variant but we can assume that you know
there's many variants throughout the
genome
that are affecting the trait so in this
case if these are
um you know we can imagine if you know
uh there's m variance in the genome
um beta i is the effect of each one
most of these will be zero but you know
many will be non-zero and um
so if we could if this is the the true
model that's kind of generating the data
of course this is a simplification
because
we're not allowing for kind of gene gene
interactions there's no interaction
effects there's also
we're assuming that everything is
additive as well that's also not
realistic
but i'm going to show that even under
this assumption of this very simple
model
like a lot of problems come up so
now let's look back again at when we're
testing a single snip
in the context of this model okay so now
um
let's say i'm looking i'm doing a g wash
and my data comes from this model where
there's many snips that are associated
but i'm only looking at i'm looking at
one step at a time let's say that
currently i'm looking at snip k what
happens is that the data actually
looks kind of like this so k has an
effect
but the other snips also have an effect
but when i'm doing my single
uh my linear model to do the test what
i'm doing is i'm only looking at
um i'm kind of ignoring these other the
rest
the effect of the rest of the snips okay
so this is what i'm calling unmodeled
factors
okay so in many cases this isn't so
bad okay this this doesn't have an
effect uh because in
oftentimes these unmodel factors will
just increase the variance
okay and when i'm doing this test it'll
get
sucked up into i mean my variance
estimate will be larger than what i
expect it to be
okay but it you know it'll kind of i
mean i'm estimating the variance from
the data so
it doesn't matter that my estimate or
the variance in the data isn't the real
one because
somehow it it'll work itself out
but but you know and of course another
thing is is that i want to emphasize
that these
factors are unknown if i knew the effect
sizes of all the other snips in
in the genome then i wouldn't be doing
association in the first place because
why would i why would i do that i would
know that um okay so
now i'm going to give you an in
in mouse genetics just to give you an
idea of where these problems come with
these unmodel factors okay so
i work a lot in mouse genetics mice are
these are mostly what kind of
like medical mouse genetics looks at
these inbred strains of mice that
are not really from a natural population
so they've been inbred
these are three different strains of
mice they obviously have very different
observable phetotypic differences but
not only that they have
just because of why they've been bred
they have many different
human disease-related phenotype
differences like macular some have
macular degeneration
some are are really susceptible to
diabetes
et cetera so if
we were involved in this in a study in
2007 looking
at the basically the genetic diversity
of these mice
involved in some kind of early
sequencing study and this is actually
one of the figures of the
paper to summarize um kind of a very
high level overview of the history of
um of these mice so essentially you have
these three subspecies of mice
that you know arose like a long time ago
and um in asia initially
initially in asia people decided to have
mice as pets
okay and so they started breeding them
similar to how we have
pets here and then in victorian england
uh people also decided to have
mice's pets and they actually bred these
pet these kind of
english pets with these asian pets to
try to make kind of really exotic
looking
pet mice and that actually created
and then then about a hundred years ago
um
in someone bought these mice
pet mice and essentially inbred them and
then these mice are now
like one of the foundations of medical
research okay so
um my point here is is that
the the genetic composition of the mice
that we use today
is really um it's really complex
and it's completely arbitrary okay uh
and
and comes from accidental okay so um
you know in a study actually an original
study on this we
we looked at 38 inbred strains of mice
and
we took their genome and we genera we
just drew a tree for them okay clearly
there's not a tree because they're
this is a we just used phylip on this
but this is just a visualization because
they're actually bred with each other
and there's a lot of really complex
sharing and since they're inbred there's
really no notion of
who's the parent of who because that
concept gets really gets really lost
when
things are inbred but you can really but
just as a visualization to give you a
kind of a high level view
you can see that there's really two
major groups here
between um like among these 38 strains
okay and one of the groups
these these two groups and that's a very
long branch link between these two
groups
and one of these groups is uh what are
called classical inbred strains
so these are the strains that actually
are mostly descendant
from what were the pets pet mice
okay and then these wild derived strains
uh these are the mice that if you wanted
to if you want to create a wild drive
straight you would
found a find a mice mouse in your
kitchen
you would like or caught in the wild you
would then breed it for 20 generations
like brother
brother sister mating and then you would
get a wild direct strain so these are
mice that are
that were not you know were never pets
okay
and so you can imagine and they're
actually pretty far apart okay
genetically
so you can imagine that and actually all
the wild derived are also very far apart
from each other as well
um you can imagine that there would be
very different traits
between wild mice and um kind of like
what were pet mice okay
so can anyone imagine what would be a
good
trait for a wild mouse like if you were
a wild mouse
what would you want to be
yeah like fast yeah smart
right um also small right all these kind
of escape
you know and when if you imagine humans
breed breed um breed
like mice okay breed pets what do they
want
what do they what kind of traits would
they want
yeah like dumb right blind yeah actually
so i think dumb and blind
are inadvertent because the the smart
ones
and the fast ones they essentially
escape and they leave the gene pool
right
um but they also people like kind of big
furry mice right and actually since i
live in los angeles now i have to
change this because people now are
breeding dogs
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller so that kind of goes against my
theory but
at least with mice people like big mice
okay so if you look at phenotypes
between these two groups
essentially if you look at body weight
every
every classical inbred mouse is larger
than
every uh wild derived mouse okay so now
let's go back
okay so now so now let's say that we're
interested in doing association with
body weight
uh of between the mice um
like between like the association of
body weight in the mouth okay
so what when you do association this is
kind of what you expect to see
okay so this is a manhattan manhattan
plot for those
uh people not not familiar with this
essentially that's the mouse genome
okay on the x-axis and the vertical line
is essentially the measure the
significance
of the correlation between that genetic
variant and the trait
and this is what you expect to see you
expect to see that there
you know most of the genome is not
correlated with the trait okay
and a you know few places you have some
correlation okay and you can kind of
quantify that
by what basically looking at the
cumulative p-value distribution
okay so the cumulative p of distribution
will will should look
follow this line y equals x why
because in general p values when there's
no
there's no effect should be randomly
distributed between zero and one
and we expect if there's a tiny fraction
of
um associations then right around zero
we should see an enrichment but for most
of the range there shouldn't be anything
and then the qq plot is exactly the same
as a cumulative
value distribution but it's just
basically looking on the log scale
so you're essentially zooming into that
small part
so that's why but like most of you know
this part of the line is kind of
you know a compressed version of the
majority of that line so
they really should follow what's
expected they really should follow
what's expected okay
so of course um what did we see we saw
this
okay so we saw virtually every loci
every every gene every position of the
genome had huge associations with body
weight
um we were very excited at first we
thought we
we even had this crazy idea that we were
gonna engineer
you know like the world's largest mouse
right
um so but then we talked to uh
some people and they pointed out that we
should run these qq plots and this is
what our qq plots look like and if
anyone's that human geos they know that
that looks actually pretty funny
so so what's going on um and
in some sense you know you can't really
blame the association method because
this is what's going on so here's
actually a snip now
we have this purple and green allele and
this snip
basically separates between uh
the classical mice and the domestic mice
and also
if you look at it just looking at it
right you would say that hey the snip is
highly correlated with body weight
right it's not doing any i mean the the
association test is doing the right
thing
but we know that that that sounds kind
of weird
um and the intuition is is that if we
somehow if
i show you the phylogeny again you can
say like oh okay well i don't really
care about this snip this snip can't be
the one because
you know look there's the the the tree
somehow
and the snip are telling me the same
information so somehow this the tree
gives you some information to say that
oh i don't really i want to discount the
snip because it's just
tracking the information of the tree
okay so
let me let me just summarize kind of a
graphical model to make it clearer so
we have two in general where we're
measuring
um correlation we're interested in
understanding if the
phenotype is is correlated with the snip
and we have two hypotheses the null
hypothesis is that they're independent
okay and the alternate hypotheses is
that they're
you know that that that they're they'd
be correlated okay so if that's the case
we could just test to see if there is
correlation between these two
and that would distinguish between
between these two hypotheses
um unfortunately if we have population
structure or some kind of relatedness
with
individuals because of these kind of
unknown factors what happens is that
this population structure will affect
many snips
so many snips will be um you know kind
of
really uh will be if you can get this
long branch length any snips along that
branch length
will be kind of uh like the population
structure will affect
the the values of any snips similarly
the population structure just because
you know in this case we had
different selection pressure on the
wild and domestic mess they affect the
feta types and so that kind of induces
correlation between many snips and the
phenotype
okay so in this case when we have
population structure what happens is
that
both in the in the scenario that the
snip doesn't affect the trait
and if the snip does affect the trait we
see that there's a correlation between
the snip
and the phenotype so checking for that
correlation
actually is doesn't is not able to to
give us what we want which is to
understand if the snip is affecting the
trait um
so and so there's actually um many
papers actually or the early papers in
in
this mouse giwas actually didn't correct
for population structure
and they were looking at very small
samples some were looking at like 16
mice and stuff like that
um and but they were able to report
these great associations
because they the population structure
which is actually
if you think about it it's actually not
such a bad thing
because had they if they didn't report
the associations then nobody
would have actually gone in got excited
about and worked in that area to find
the problems and so now
um so actually we would never i wouldn't
be here today
right if it wasn't for these papers so
i'm very grateful
these are the pioneers yeah i'm very
grateful
okay so um so okay so let's go back so
what's going on so we again we have
these unmodeled factors and again these
unmodel factors
are what's essentially you know kind of
their their the effects of the snips of
these unmodel factors you can think of
on different sides of that long branch
length is what's
really confounding our ability to do
association
um and so so we we we obviously can't
know this but we can know something
about this
by taking this idea which we can say
that okay let's look
pairwise between let's say our mouse
drain so here's actually
two two mount two uh classical
these are two classical inbred strains
black six and c3h
and they are very like very similar
genomes
okay and so let's uh this is a toy
example i'm looking at ten snips
okay and they're nine out of ten of
these snips are the same
so let's just you know from this toy
example assume that all the even number
snips are actual causal variants that
have
kind of a non-zero beta that affect the
trait okay
so i might i will not know i i might not
know
what that what those values are but i
will know
that these two strains will have a
similar value for their
unknown confounding for that that kind
of unmodeled factor
because so many of their snips are the
same okay
on the other hand if i look at castaneus
which is a wild drive strain
you know in this case almost all the
snips are different so
you know if the same snips are causal
for the i also won't know necessarily
what the values of these unbottled
factors are for each of these
but i'll know that but i can predict
that they would be
different from each other okay and if i
generalize this and look at kind of all
pairs
and if i just if i actually just make a
matrix
which just contains how many share how
many snips are shared in each pair
um what what do i uh you know what what
does that give me so that gives that
gives me
kind of a a blueprint for which which
pairs have similar values for those
unmolded factors and which ones which
ones have
dissimilar values and so the the key
idea
uh behind what what our work here is
that
what we do is we extend the
simple model to include a term
which is basically a random effect
okay that somehow captures these
unmodeled factors and that
the basic idea is that the uh
these unmodeled factors will have a
covariance the this this random
this random vector which we know
obviously we're going to try to estimate
from the data
is going to have a covariance structure
which is going to be dependent on how
much of the genome these are shared
okay so the and then using kind of a
likelihood model will be able to kind of
fit the data in order
to to estimate and and to correct for
this okay
so that's that's the idea behind linear
mixed models
and it turns out that if i go back to my
hypothetical true model
and i just add the assumption that these
beta i's
are are actually drawn from a normal
distribution
with effect size um with with
with mean zero and variance sigma
squared g
then what what happens is that um
it turns out that that using a mixed
model
a linear mix model and
making that assumption and just doing
kind of bayesian regression with that
assumption
are equivalent under some kind of like
normalization of the genotypes and some
other assumptions that are a little bit
technical and i'm not
not going to get here so this is kind of
the basics of
of mixed models and kind of why they
work and
here's actually so so this is kind of
again the linear mixed model so
kind of the nuts and bolts of how it's
used so you have
a um you have this this model
um you have it's called the mix model
because you have both
uh fixed effects which are you're trying
to estimate like the mean
uh beta i the the snap the effect of the
snip
and you're also trying to estimate these
random effects and particularly
try to estimate these parameters like uh
sigma squared g
and sigma squared e which are like the
kind of the variance
like how much of the variance is
captured by the
kind of interrelatedness of the
individuals and how much of the
variances
is just environmental variance and
um when you're doing and you're
essentially taking your data and you're
trying to fit all these parameters and
then
you can look at a kind of a potentially
an f
test to compare if you have a snip
effect versus not to get a p-value
but the key step is you have to estimate
all these parameters and this can be
kind of difficult so you have to
estimate these
these variance components sigma square g
sigma squared e and the traditional
approaches
um were very very inefficient um
and so we actually came up with a a
method this is actually
a a while ago called emma for doing the
the estimates and i'm covering it here
because
um i think it's it's still important to
kind of and it's a
really simple way to understand like
what the more kind of more recent uh
developments and mixed models are yeah
what's what's k again okay is the the
k is the um kind of pairwise
genetic relatedness between individuals
estimated from all the snips okay
is there any this is a good point for a
question is that
yeah so it seems like you're building
some type of distance matrix to take
into account the phylogenetic
correlation or whatever
yes yes but then there's also some
implicit assumption about independence
between sites
is that uh there's a lot of assumptions
no no no i'm saying there's a lot of
assumptions and there's
a lot of actually work now kind of
improving mixed models kind of
unraveling
different effects of assumptions so i'm
just thinking like linkage might
for yeah so like things there's like a
whole line of work saying how to
estimate kinship matrices taking into
account ld
should you should you not does it affect
it does it not there's like a lot yeah
yeah so but i mean that's a great
question and great intuition
um but i'm here now kind of there's like
a lot of caveats that i'm kind of
ignoring just to kind of give the high
level
thread any any more questions on that
okay
so so anyway so so now we get to kind of
like a little technical
uh so we want to estimate these variance
components so
so um how does emma work so here's the
here's actually the
kind of the basics okay so you want to
compute the likelihood of your data
okay for a mixed model and
um you here's actually so you're likely
the data will now follow a multivariate
normal distribution
okay with a certain var the variance
will be
basically sigma squared g times the
kinship matrix plus sigma squared e
times the identity matrix
and there's also a fixed effect beta
and this is the likelihood this is the
likelihood
that you want to compute and the
difficulty is is that
your variance actually is a function of
your parameters sigma squared g
and sigma squared e and you have to
invert it
um in order to compute the likelihood
and so as you're searching in that
parameter space
every time you have to invert the matrix
and so this is actually why
the original implementations of mixed
models were really
like unusable because you know if you
imagine you had to do this for like a a
large data set with a lot of snips and
that every iteration you had to
do this inversions that was really
difficult and so
uh human kang in my lab who's now a
faculty of michigan
really came up with this insight which
uh
called the emma trick and the new kind
of methods for
mixed model optimization are also used
very similar ideas so the basic idea is
that
you you represent k instead of just
treating k in its natural form what you
do is you you basically do
a eigenvalue decomposition
okay and you get the eigenvectors and
the eigenvalues and you represent it as
you know you is this is diagonalized
form
and so then the the v matrix
is just going to be basically the
because you know because
the identity matrix is also diagonalized
as well
it's always diagonal um you could just
represent the the v
like this and then if you also you
compute the z matrix which is kind of
like
the u transpose times the the fixed
effects
and after you do this the likelihood
becomes
essentially this okay and if you notice
is that you know this part is inverted
right here
okay but now you're just this inverted
part
is just you're inverting in every step
when you're
iterating over these two parameters
you're inverting something that's
already diagonal
so you that doesn't take any time so
that's the whole
idea behind it and that's kind of so you
you have to only once
compute this uh spectral decomposition
and then
um and then the rest of it is is pretty
fast and so people since that time have
kind of done some improvements to
actually kind of get rid of the fact
that you
you need to do this for every snip so
like they're newer methods that are
there
that are faster but this is the the
basic idea um so
um this is what after applying emma to
the same data
we saw no association with body weight
this is an example where we saw nothing
and we were very excited
that we saw nothing and but we did find
some other associations and so since
that time
there's been a a lot of you know emma's
gotten kind of a cult following in
various like non-human non-human systems
and kind of a lot of plant
and we've been very interested in
applying emma to mouse genetics and so
since that time they've been
uh our group and other groups have been
very involved in mouse g
wasps and so for those people who are
um you know either interested or not
interested in human geos
maybe you can look at mouse duos i think
there's a lot of interesting problems
and interesting things to
do there and um there's also a human
counterpart
mx as well and i'm actually going to
skip
over it a little bit because i want to
get to the
some newer work okay so um so that was
mixed models and so the
the idea so that was the basic idea so
the idea is that actually
uh these techniques are actually much
more general than
for correcting for population structure
but they can be used
for generate confounding so what i'm
interested here i'm going to talk about
for the
my uh my remaining time is about
eqtl studies okay this is an area of
interest uh
by the community where you're trying to
understand
how genetic variation affects expression
okay
and um what i'm particularly so so what
so
if you look at kind of the most basic
thing that you can do is that
you know you have the expression level
of let's say m genes gene one through
gene
gene m you know the basic analysis is to
just do a
genome-wide association study for each
one of these
these genes so you end up with the it's
very
difficult though to visualize it in this
way if you have this kind of
you know stack of uh you know 20 000
manhattan plots so what we do just just
for visualization
is we basically rotate them
vertically okay and we stack them one
along and we look
down on them okay and essentially we cut
off
make up make a cut off okay so this is
looking so
on the x-axis are the snip locations
on the y-axis are the probe locations
okay and the intensity of a point if
it's above some value
is essentially the association
measure the association between the snip
and the probe okay so it's the same
information just
visualizing it in a different way so we
can actually see all of it together
um okay so so this is a kind of an eqtl
plot this is actually
a classic data set collected by uh
um leonard kruglach and so you can just
looking at it
you see some really obvious structures
here okay
so one structure that you see so first
yes again this is what i meant to say
this is actually
looking at about three thousand markers
and about six thousand expressions
okay um so one real obvious structure
is this kind of diagonal band
okay and that's what we call the cis
eqtl band
okay that's basically snips that are
affecting
um themselves i mean snips that are
genes that
that affect the expression of genes that
they're in or near
okay and we expect that to be true these
are you know could be sniffs and
promoters etc
okay um the and and and
it's good that we see this because that
kind of gives us a measure
of true positives if we don't if you do
an analysis and you don't see one you
know that
something went really horribly wrong
like maybe your
sample ids are off or something like
that so another
very interesting structure is basically
these
these vertical lines okay and this is
actually what i would say is the most
what brings the most interest so these
are what's called
um uh trans regulatory bands these are
snips
okay that then affect
kind of genome-wide patterns of gene
expression okay
and these are really interesting for a
lot of reasons so this is a snip that
affects many
probes okay and one of the real
interesting
and kind of nicely maybe the snip
actually affects some kind of a master
regulator
right that then has many downstream
effects okay so this is actually
really what we want we want to actually
identify these master regulators that
might give us a lot of information about
kind of how the
expressions the structure of expression
in in
in that tissue so this is actually very
important to identify but of course we
don't
we don't see that directly we only see
the correlation between
this in this data the snip and all these
other uh
all these um other uh these genes
but we like to that's that's why it's of
so such interest
so we're actually very interested in
these um in these
uh expression these these hot spots
regulatory hot spots um and uh which
would translate into bands and hot spots
are the same thing so
are defined to be the same thing so we
want to look at this if we look at this
really classic data set there's this
classic data set
of looking at bxd mice that reported a
lot of hot spots
and they actually did something very
interesting so bxc bikes are inbred
strains of mice so you can actually get
identical twins of the same
basically genetic animal and what they
did was they actually collected
two animals per strain okay
and collected expression in each one and
then what they did was they
just averaged the expression values
together
and then did their analysis other their
eqtl analysis on there
and they reported many things so we
thought oh this is perfect you know
why don't what we do because we're
interested in things like power
robustness etc
why don't we just you know randomly you
know
pick one of the strains into one group
okay do the eqtl analysis
in one you know in one for one rep set
of replicates
and for for the second set of replicates
and then we can maybe compare to see
you know first of all how similar are
they to each other you know
how similar are they to the to the
combined analysis et cetera
okay and so in order to do that we need
to have somehow quantify
the strength of of hot spots okay so how
how strong is a hot spot and so for this
you know
we have a kind of real heuristic
approach here which is that
we just take in that column we just sum
all the negative log p
values together okay and that just gives
us some kind of a measure of
how hot spots ish is that is that probe
so that's
really has no meaning but it's just
useful for visualization so for example
if i if i look here you can see that
where there's a lot of red
that our little kind of heuristic is
high and when there's not a lot of red
it's lower okay so just a way
to visualize okay so we did this
here is actually what we found um uh so
this is red is a red is one
like replicated green is the other so we
found that they're
inconsistent between the replicants okay
so we said oh that's really weird well
maybe it's like a power
issue okay so let's randomize the data
and try again see what happens
so then we randomized the data and then
we found that we actually the randomized
data we found even stronger hot spots
than we found in unrandomized data
so that was really weird right and we
actually found that that in our
our original data was particularly not
strong it's not a p-value of only 0.89
okay for the strongest hotspot so that's
really weird
um so so what's going on so then what we
did is we actually
uh used because we were doing emma at
the time so we used the same code of
emma to compute
essentially kind of like a kinship
matrix but between the arrays themselves
okay so and to generate these kind of
inner sample correlation plots so let me
explain
exactly what this plot is so um each
each row and column so so each of these
each of these dots
represents the correlation between an
array so a
gene expression array might have like 20
000 measurements
and it's just the correlation between
those two vectors and
here's actually so so and so of course
like
we have one replicate on so so along the
diagonals
is because we have two strains it's like
the replicate
the the two replicates within straight
against each other
this is one replicate you know one pair
of replicates
this is another pair of replicas okay so
we would expect to see a lot of
enrichment along this diagonal
and we don't see that uh in this in this
data and furthermore if you look at this
data you see there's a clear batch
effect
okay it looks like and when we looked at
the dates we saw that
these guys were all collected together
and then these guys were all collected
together
right so within the vast so we saw this
okay so
then what our our hypothesis is is that
you know
the snip might actually be not
correlated with
you know some kind of master regulator
but might correlate with some kind of
systematic confounding which then
induces correlation
with the the array so and we actually we
tested that by doing the following we
basically
take our original data we looked at this
inner sample correlation matrix from the
data
then we generated simulated data just
using that same covariance structure
and then ran our read our approach and
what we saw is we saw that
all the hot spots are in the same place
so it's actually the inner sample
correlation matrix is enough to explain
where the hot spots
occur and so then
here's actually a kind of a graphical
model explaining this so we have
um we have like movement have some real
hot spots like the snip might be
affecting these
these three genes but then we also have
some kind of confounding factors like
batch effects that might be affecting
you know all the other genes and so just
sometimes by chance a snip
might be correlated but with a
compounding factor and because we have
so many snips that can happen
right we have thousands of snips so then
this snip will look like
it's a it's a confounding factor okay so
um
so how do we uh so okay so this is
basically so we actually came up with a
a the same idea to address this so why
don't we just take this
this inner sample correlation matrix and
then use that
as our kind of like the same way that we
use the
genetic similarity matrix in in in emma
to
to to correct for it so um so we did
that so what does that do so that
basically
it's kind of like we're conditioning on
all the gene expression values
okay and then what happens is that we're
then blocking
the kind of effect of this confounding
factor so then this snip will no longer
be a hot spot
okay because um because we kind of took
this effect out that's like
that's essentially what we did
unfortunately what also happens is that
when we when we condition all this we
also if there's a real hot spot we also
kind of uh get rid of that as well okay
so this is actually so if you look at
before and after this is that we have a
method called ice
and um so we eliminate all the hot spots
but there's a
so so so but one of the interesting
things is that
these bands this kind of diagonal band
the cis band
actually got a lot stronger so in some
sense we're capturing more signal
um here's actually some plots showing
that
uh between replicates and across tissues
we do better okay we actually captures
more and then
um
and we capture more okay so so the
question so this is
so so the question is so so at the time
um
we there was still a question which was
you know do hotspots really exist
okay and um we really didn't have a way
to
to so let me just summarize what does
ice say so ice basically says
that this this work says that um
we these confounding factors
can induce hot spots okay um
and we have a that we know and then um
snips actually can be correlated with
those confounding factors causing hot
spots
but then also there may be other hot
spots so our technique to remove that
okay also removes real hot spots and so
um at the time we actually thought that
they didn't exist okay
and um we were and you know if we had a
blog
imagine what we could have done right
so but it turns out right around the
same
you know like like leonid kruglach
actually happened to move
who collected the original data happened
to move from seattle to
um to princeton and he redid his
experiment
okay and um if you look at the two data
these are the two data sets for the
collective 2005 2008
and if you look at the overlap between
the two of them
um they're actually hot spots so what's
actually shared between so this is a
proof
and actually there's also protein
activity levels that you also measure
that
fat from the same places so actually
show that these these
these things do exist um but our
so these are the where the true hot
spots are again this is just the overlap
between these two
are true hotspots but ice kind of
eliminates them so
um so this is actually we were stuck for
for
for many years and i'm happy to report
that we actually had a new idea
not too long ago for how to address this
and our basic intuition
is this is that and is that
hot spots like things like batch effects
will affect all genes okay but genetic
factors will only affect a subset of
genes it's not plausible to think that a
genetic factor will affect half of the
genes or you know something like that
so the genetic true genetic effects will
always should be stronger than
compounding effects they'll be affected
by both
true genetic factors and any batch
effects and so if we correct for
confounding using only the weaker genes
um then we would basically block the hot
spots and not
the other so for example here's actually
if i rank if these genes are ranked by
the strength of the effect
then if i just use the bottom genes
it'll somehow block the confounder
the effect of the compounder but not the
actual
true hotspot and so this led to our
method
named nice next generation ice right we
figured why not
um and um so we actually this is what
the true hot spots these are the eqtl
plots and this is kind of just a
visualization so
the overlapped identified 10 hot spots
and
um if if you look at ice uh so nice
basically
is able to to predict so again we'll
look i didn't explain experiment we're
looking at the 2005 data
analyzing it and then using the 2008
data to verify
whether or not we actually like what's
real and what's not real
what sort of left not so nice is able to
identify
nine hot spots with two spurs hot spots
while ice was actually
only missed a lot of them um and so
there's other projects i'm happy to talk
to people in the remaining part of the
conference
uh while we're here and um
i'd like to acknowledge there's a lot
this covered election
many years like this little long thread
in our lab so
hugh ming kang and jimmy yee um
were were actually kind of pioneers of
the ice and
emma and joanne um is now currently
that she's she's working on nice and um
that papers
should be coming out soon and j'hoon and
uh
actually and noah and boom were also
involved and then
all the mouse stuff that we did at ucla
has been with jake luces
and uh emma x was done with kiara
sabatti
and this is our live website thanks
i mean yeah that could i mean that could
have been yeah yeah well
we actually did miss we did miss one
right and so we think that that was the
one yeah
any other questions what's the
relationship between
the regression and uh
okay yay so this is actually very
closely related so
if you normalize you know assuming
you're normalizing things in
correctly the same way then actually
your heritability
will be your estimate of sigma squared g
divided by sigma squared g plus sigma
squared e
so it's actually very similar so the the
real thing that
fischer fisher i mean there's a
one of the things that i'd like to
mention there is that when i talk about
this normalization that means that
you're
kind of making assumptions about um
you know like kind of how different
minor allele frequencies affect
different traits and so that actually
goes in those things that i swept under
the rug
greatly affect uh these kind of
estimates of heritability but
that basic technique is is the same
do you think that technique estimate of
heritability has any use
um i mean why do people estimate
heritability
um that's a great question um
i think i i think that
so practically
i think that the main the main there's a
there's a bunch of reasons why
one is it gives you the upper bound of
what you can find in association studies
so that might give you guidance to know
if how much more
money should you put in how many big
larger samples
um it also gives you an idea of maybe
that there's information in the data
that we're not
directly able to implicate the the
variance that's one thing right
i think that's probably the biggest
thing i think also it
answers it can give you some insights
into
fundamental questions about what is the
genetic architecture of traits
okay looking at the heritability and how
the heritability
is partitioned into different
kind of classes of allele frequencies
gives you something about you know give
you some information
into trying to understand the
architecture of the traits
thank you